je peux pas
[Musique]
j'étais décrocheuse soit parce que
j'avais pas l'école j'aime bien ça c'est
plutôt par rapport à la structure
scolaire cursus scolaire c'est derrière
un bureau est
tu fais que ça pendant les
[Musique]
le décrochage scolaire si quelqu'un bat
qui s'imaginent qu'il aura tout cuit
dans le bec sont fermement de raifort
jean louis
elle a bien voulu me reprendre et que
j'étais comme les romains quand je le
dis depuis tout petit j'ai jamais été
très pâle et enfin ça me s'était pas
montré qu'en fait je trouvais qu'il y
avait des réflexions pas juste donc j'ai
hésité pas à le dire parce que j'ai une
grande bouche comme n'était pas
intéressé par le thème pas moi j'allais
plus en cours
badji à l'été ça merde c'est à dire
c'était vraiment l'apocalypse j'étais
une très bonne élève à la base et à
partir du collège on s'est un peu servi
de moi comme moteur est en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que j'étais plutôt
entraînée vers le bas dans 20 minutes
mais une note ont diminué avec mais pas
de jour de retard
on a réduit les peines va
ou même de la philosophie comme
[Musique]
maintenant je suis clean de porte une
cravate autour est la main ne pas je
trouve que ça fait de porter les deux à
huawei se dévouent de l'eifel satin de
quoi ça a commencé assez tôt parce que
en fait
je trouvais les profs les systèmes de
notation ça je mets ça que c'était en
fait j'espère ça totalement débile et
depuis depuis qu'une toute petite
enquête apparaît très bizarre c'était
alors j'ai tout petit j'avais de très
bonnes notes mais je n'ai pas du tout il
y avait une feuille de cérémonial autour
des notes de la directrice qui venait
pour mettre les bulletins des petits
cadeaux de sas complètement débile et
très pour ce qui était mon bon c'était
tout raide et enfin je sais pas s'il
fera baisser au maximum et je n'ai pas
du tout ça et ça m'a très vite dégoûté
par me not on commence à chuter jusqu'à
la main seront que j'ai redoublé et j'en
fais plus j'ai craqué donc bah j'ai
arrêté depuis janvier je cherche un
autre établissement en pet
qu'est ce que tu trouves de bien dans
son c on n'a pas les mêmes relations
avec les profs qu'on peut avoir dans un
lycée traditionnelle et je sais pas il
ya plus de confiance les cours ils sont
pas pareils et puis c'est plus basé vers
l'humanitaire comme moi personnellement
c'est ce que je veux faire plus tard
ben c'est sûr que voilà quoirin que les
cours quoi il m'intéresse assez des
cours qui m'intéresse dans le lycée jean
lurçat l'humanitaire est un outil
pédagogique on va dire même si
parallèlement à ça
le lycée jean lurçat mène une
association qui s'appelle dire à qui
elle a clairement pour but d'aider le
village de diraz on a travaillé nos
agents de bananier on a continué le
travail qui a été qu'ils avaient établi
l'année dernière par d'autres élèves
duels et si ensuite on a fait de
l'animation dans l'école du village
les après midi et deux heures de haut à
2 heures et un dispensaire
ouais un stage dans un dispensaire y en
a qui l'ont fait une semaine de quatre
jours
fait un point d'eau dans l'école du
village ici les profs c'est pas comme
structure traditionnelle c'est pas genre
tu vois tu parles tard est en droit
d'obtenir il parle culte et choix c'est
tout c'est à dire que tu parles voilà
ils te laissent la parole tu donnes ton
avis et il n'y a jamais de 3 voilà il ya
jamais eu de tension avec les profs mais
jamais jamais jamais parce que ya pas de
jeu voilà tu as le droit à la parole 30
exprimé dire ce que tu penses tu envie
de dire merde tout du maire
ces voix là ils prennent comme quelqu'un
de normal qui choisit pas il ya les
adultes les enfants et son supérieur et
nous trouvons la permanence comme un
truc comme ça tu vois ça ça aide aussi
ça merci sûr c'est pas comme moi comme
elle a dû comme les lycées traditionnel
il est prof et disent tiens le par
exemple et mûri et blanc et profondeur
le mulet noah répète maintenant il est
blanc non il est noir basta c'est moi
qui ait le dernier mot je suis c'est la
hiérarchie tac en haut de la pyramide
toi tu étais tout en bas c'est moi qui
fais les cours moi j'ai déjà c'est ma
vie tu fais tes courses et bien que j'ai
fais pas moi j'ai mon salaire à la fin
du mois non ici c'est bah tu es là tu es
là pourquoi pour compte remettre à
niveau pour qu'on fasse que pour que tu
aille au bout de tes rêves
on va on va t'aider aller au bout du
tunnel et plus ça ici
pas de travail
à sofia
peu présente et voilà c'était tout comme
ça c'était l'année dernière mentor ça à
l'élève n'a pas ça l'est pas mais ça
allait par rapport aux 2 les dames
mais les années d'avant par contre
c'était mou c'est un base de perturber
le cours genre pas en gros pas possible
de noter vous j'étais pas là et voilà
c'était plein de trucs comme ça ça a
bien changé
ici c'est différent et ouais c'est très
près alors donc maintenant imagine
félicitations investi nain magnifique et
là genre encouragements et tout ce qu'il
y avait un petit peu moins de régularité
mais c'était encore chaud ça c'est là
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on manie non
parce qu'il ya vraiment un butin donc
moi on m'a mis les félicitations
bon travail participe un élément moteur
qu'on veut les félicitations ont la même
signification oui je laissais nationale
je crois c'est vous avez l'air de les
avoir tous il faudra dire là certes nous
trois on les a eus c'est à dire du toit
dans la classe on et 26 quand même enfin
26-25 enfin les plus jeunes d'athènes
quoi donc c'est pas forcément tout le
monde il y en a qui travaillent comme
d'autres qui ne travaillent pas faut
dire aussi qu'ils sont là on est des
décrocheurs scolaires et donc si tu
travailles pas de bêtes façon conseil de
classe des toits que les parents ils
viennent parce que c'est pas ça
s'appelle un conseil de progrès c'est
déjà les parents viennent vers 6 voilà
c'est à dire que les parents suivent etc
comme l'a dit impliqué et leur base ceux
qui travaillent pas assez dit comme ça
devant tout le monde xna route normale
car maintenant ils disent certes et
démotive pas les dents courage tu as et
encouragea est en confiance faire
remonter ces jamais dire on est là par
décourager at enfonce encore plus ça il
faut toujours tout au tout ils décriront
peut-être pas les félicitations
lille les encourageant mais qu'ils se
diront oralement et c'est ça aussi qui
sait
qu'ils me donnent envie de moi qu'on va
partir récupérer la conscience que les
parents avaient perdu vos arguments
terre va plus du tout confiance des jeux
disait quelque chose à ma mère pour elle
tous basés sur fait c'était juste une
fin 3 pour elle c'était tout était une
fin témoin tout ce qu'elle me disait je
pouvais pas l'entendre
d'ailleurs avec celle des pensions je
parlais pas d une semaine d un mois des
demandes je parlais pas sa mère
après ce couac c'est bien ah ouais là ça
va c'est pour traquer
ouais je dis pas non mais j'aime bien
mettre par la vie de tous les jours
genre une passion c'est
tout ce qui est comme ça bon
j'arrive pas à faire une figure
à moins d'un plus âgés que moi ou
quelqu'un qui est plus forte qui
m'aident la oca j'écoute j'écoute
attentivement
c'est parce que t'es tu as bien faire du
bmx
[Musique]
si tu aimes pas l'école tapant évoqué
cite enfin ici si tu as envie de
joie joie y en a qui viennent pas trop
qui venait pas trop au début de l'année
maintenant ils viennent plus et ils ont
vraiment il
et c'est comme ça que après ils veulent
bien colisée les professeurs ça ne
dérange pas
de toison à longueur de temps les
proviseurs et à dire que tu peux non
mais tu te situes mais ici c'est que tu
sois aussi envie d'un côté de jacques
tati a eu le déclic un surnom ighli coup
je n'ai pas
vous êtes forcément raison forcément
raison parce que je peux pas ne pas dire
je sais que je suis que vous vous êtes
de l'établissement c'est que vous avez
passé déjà un an d un projet vraiment ça
va être un autre
3 2 donc tu sais comme le catch c'est
comme le lycée
je supporte l'om mais moi ce que je veux
dire quand la ces gens revoient en
quelque sorte a besoin compte est si tu
viens ici placés pour venir à lui assure
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
vu que ça va faire une heure on parle
tous ensemble c'est pour ça que je
commence à prendre conscience qu'un et
après tout qu'il faut que je bouge pas c
faut il faut que je fasse quelque chose
[Musique]
mais en tant que décrocheurs scolaires
on veut te remettre dans le système
scolaire pour par par parlait de par
départ les stages que tu va effectuer tu
vas en effectuant certainement début de
l'année prochaine s'est est pris ensuite
bas si tout se passe bien si tu viens au
projet sénégal c'est à dire toi c'est le
projet partenariat comme zen égal tu
iras etc et faut être fort aussi parce
que voiture balai au sénégal c'est clair
que ça va être complètement différent
la terre va être fort psychologiquement
tu vas voir tu vas avoir des trucs que
tu auras jamais vu faut bien s'intégrer
il faut que tu sois là quoi présent
c'est très simple vous avez beaucoup
filmé en fait tout le temps presque tous
les jours on avait une caméra le gazon
douter sur les bananeraies vite fait tu
vois une fois au mont pour montrer ces
conditions ça je trouve assez facilement
on va faire une vidéo il faut tester de
nombreuses coupes à des scènes de
terreur jeunes puisque j'ai dix races et
les internats
quand vous étiez là quoi alors que nous
quand vous étiez pas là bas on affine
mais quand même un peu donc vraie
demande à stéphanie cano amène sa les
gouro base cette image de jeunesse bien
comment tout ça
[Musique]
là
non
au sénégal le ciel et la terre avant le
premier jour on a assisté à un
accouchement et c'est un simple à ce
moment là on s'est dit ware elle a
vraiment envie de continuer ce stage et
s'était assis tht mèche c'est dur à voir
c'est fait ça et ça fait mal quand même
moment on a vraiment envie de pleurer
parce que les gamins comme les femmes
comme les hommes
ils sont vraiment malades quand ils ont
paludisme où ils sont sous ma nutrition
déshydraté français c'est horrible mais
ça reste magnifique dit toi tu vas aller
dans la brousse quoi tu vas être
vraiment au sénégal sa façon touristique
quoi je vais y être
tu auras pas y aura pas d'électricité
l'auto rate et zap des horaires pour
pour l'eau ça va être ça va être
vraiment là la vraie vie on va là-bas et
des c'est pas comme si on allait
sûrement des vacances et tout ça o'toole
année ça s'est construit d'un projet
avant d'y aller et qu'on était là bas et
on connait allez on s'est senti vraiment
des bandes et des gens qui nous faisait
sentir chez nous on rencontrait plein
des problèmes qu'avant on n'avait pas
rencontré aux passants moi j'ai fait de
l'animation avec une classe des 60 télé
en fait le voyage au sénégal encore le
ciel ça nous a rapprochés mais tout ça
montre qu'ils complètement différent et
en vente il ya certaines choses nous ont
pas pu tellement saoul moment où on va
pas prendre la même manière c'est à dire
que quand je pense pour toi aussi on est
pas qu'on réfléchisse plus long et plus
posé
on prend pas les choses à la panique on
laissait devait gérer calmement parce
que ce manière ça fait pas avancer forme
et plus oui plus qu'un autre c'est que
des petites choses centre de la vie que
l'on changé genre faire bien attention à
ce que la lumière soit éteinte canton
partent pas rester trop longtemps sous
l'eau au saut dont la douche
enfin que des trucs comme ça mais qui
pour eux c'est énorme cela leur
apportera vrai et c'est là c'est au
sénégal qu'on s'en est rendu compte qu
elle l'ouverture sur les autres aussi
dans la classe on sait tous va se
rapprocher un ensemble
[Musique]
fait de l'apprentissage je suis rentré
dans le monde du travail j'avais 15 ans
et
et quand j'ai vu ce que c'était vraiment
bossé et quand on se retrouve dans une
école où on a des horaires assez
particulier parce que moi par moelle
comme j'étais en alimentation
comme j'étais en cuisine c'était assez
dur fin les horreurs sont pas tout à
fait
à 15 ans quand on doit se lever à 5
heures du matin au début on a un peu de
mal donc
quand on vient ici quand on vient dans
un collège on voit où dans un lycée on
voit vraiment que c'est assez bien quand
même
voilà avec la petite foule est là on
peut faire descendre
j'étais plutôt sceptique pour le voyage
est ce que je pensais que ça
m'apporterait un peu rien mais en fait
ça m'a apporté beaucoup
ça s'est vraiment bien passé et je veux
me dire qu'est ce que ça t'a apporté
ben déjà une expérience
humaine on va dire que c'est vraiment
déjà de vivre en communauté de travail
et aussi en communauté parce que on n'a
pas fait on va dire on a passé trois
semaines de vacances on a vraiment
travaillé la bâche et
et ça on apprend beaucoup sur les autres
et beaucoup sur soi même et
ça ça change beaucoup de choses en moi
ça m'a beaucoup changé c'est à dire
l'année dernière par exemple il m'aurait
dit ouah soulette c'est quoi la
prochaine fois fable maneater tu vas
être plus posé tu vas le sénégal je vais
j'ai regardé à personne mais oui mais tu
l'as tu as raison mais sincèrement ses
limites
ah non c'est grave j'ai refait ses seins
sous deux mois les ans maintenant encore
attend maintenant là c'est là c'est vrai
c'est vous dire si tous je vais vous
faire pour te dire tu vois à quel point
je ne sais pas qu'est ce qui peut se
passer d'ici demain il c'est un truc de
fou
en un an j'aurais jamais cru devrait
autant de trucs mais jamais on me dit ça
moi dans les restes dans les restaurants
[Musique]
tata
je
[Musique]
jean ne pas
gd
le
[Musique]
bordry
l'école quand jean vaillancourt je sais
je parle beaucoup mais quand on va en
cours façon et je n'ai pas l'écueil sa
douce où les profs du soul et cetera
nous pensons s'en fout on s'en fout une
fois qu'on vient ici on donne notre
confiance en nous les gens nous donnent
confiance
enfin je suis pas pour expliquer sa
jeune espoir qu'ils ont confiance en moi
et elle nous on n'a pas 70 et donc il ya
un lien qui se dit bon voilà c'est en
gros il ya contact avec le professeur
qu'on n'a pas forcément mon collège met
en contact c'est sa maladie il ya un
tuteur acheteurs c'est lui qui va dessus
tout les profs en fait il va le suivre
tout au long de l'année mais 1 hors amm
en particulier on va vraiment sur ton
parcours ce que tu vas faire les
prochaines ça ce qui sera le plus au
courant tu vois ça pour ça parce que ce
que je reproche un peu tout ce qui est
système scolaire classique c'est que
le professeur il fait son cours il a
on doit pas avoir de problème dans sa
classe et pas si un problème passé
d'exclus autant écarté puis on
s'intéresse plus à toi manifestement là
ce que j'entends depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que paillard ya un réel contact et
on n'est pas d'élèves à part bien sûr on
va pas
papa lui tous les cd non plus on va pas
on le laisse pas faire n'importe quoi
mais on a l'air de pouvoir l'aider on
essaye de l'aider en même temps à mon
avis l'élève doit doit être conscient
qu'on est là pour l'aider
donc c'est pour ça que le mais aussi
jeux valère d'avoir un caractère assez
impulsive et à l'air d'avoir été changé
mais c'est clair mais dit toi ici de
remettre à niveau mais trimestre met
aussi dans le système
dans un système où voilà quoi ya le
respect tu le comprends s'en foutent
conti pouces c'est à dire tous ses
combats ses compagnes ouais le respect
ça change d'école et c'était assez bien
mais c'est à dire c'est pas ça qui nous
pousse à être faut vraiment quelqu'un
derrière et moi comment je qualifie au
fait ça elle est si bon c'est un peu
voilà quoi c'est un peu voilà mais je
vous ai fait comme je dis mais les six
autres c'est-à-dire t on va dire surtout
les déchets de l'éducation nationale 1
mais c'est vraiment c'est tous les défis
de l'éducation nationale mais dans une
classe pour les recycler et en majorité
enfin pour moi ce que j'ai remarqué dans
ces classes scolaires
on est tous en fins de recyclage pas ça
bien recycler les choses ont poli plus
ça y est c'est fini je n'ai plus la plus
polie sûr
on fait un petit point tutorat collectif
je suis prêt à recevoir ce qui me
souhaitons ce tour individuelle après
des choses plus personnelles a abordé ce
n'est pas abordée en groupe j'aimerais
bien ça veut dire marché une fois qu'on
sera content
chacune va raconter chacun votre tour
vous en êtes le trajet personnelles et
votre trajet d'orientation dont la fs
m'énerver nouveau discuté avec le soul à
6h30 et je pense que si vous êtes à la
veille d un peu un stage dans une
entreprise une association commerce
équitable chercher elle devait passer
sous des bois fallait qu'ils le fassent
avec jean max havelaar aller que j'étais
content que ce qui me prépare un stage
de faut que ce soit par eux quoi je
devrais faire comme ça et j'en ai parlé
à mon père ne permet pas du tout et le
sénégal m'a dit tu es trop jeune et
c'est donc sa mort donc sur la première
est normal inverse a vraiment lancé
derrière contenteront te dis ça c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible tu
l'appelles avoir discuté avec laquelle
j'ai dit ça je vais avoir 18 ans en
juillet a joué dit j'ai parlé du
commerce équitable j'ai parlé tranquille
sous un angle mon père me l'a dit je
suis trop jeune 18 ans tu vas partir et
c'est un drame a joué de façon si je
pars pas là avec eux cette façon je
partirai de la maison tout courant toute
façon je le ferai de mon côté il veut
partir les passe temps je veux dire
notre maison explique je suis dit que ça
pouvait m'ouvrir plus de portes m'a fait
me suis fait attendre deux ans je fais
mais l'opportunité est que ce sera
l'année prochaine donc
caspar 6 6 me fais non jeu fera dans
deux trois ans trafic les études ce moi
je n'aime pas il voyage qui mènera moi
je parle besoin de faire du tout aux
besoins des affaires humanitaires voilà
[Musique]
je voudrais en fait rentrer dans une
école de photo
j'invite vraiment enfin les études et
j'ai envie de faire plein de choses
[Musique]
pour l'année prochaine genre projet je
vais passer trois mois au sénégal en
santé et je passe à mon concours de
meilleur éducateur des mois de chute et
j'ai voulu je voulais être maîtresse en
afrique
[Musique]
si je devais rentrer dans un lycée
normal on choisira la filière l aps
ben j'ai envie de voyager
faut voir les seconds plans de choses en
deux ans j'ai grandi plus que dans toute
ma vie
[Musique]
m
ben
non
[Musique]
là
me
[Musique]
m
in comme ça cette croissance en france 2